it's early morning on a chicken farm
near Conakry mama do telepathy is
working for a project for returned
migrants bogey himself tried to reach
Europe last year but he only made it as
far as New Year he saw many of his
friends die along the way and he was
tortured by people smugglers and thrown
in jail by soldiers after he was
released the International Organization
for Migration or IOM flew him back home
after I returned many people made fun of
me because I didn't make it but I felt
relieved I'm back home now and no one is
depressing me I'm living well in this
year we had problems with the military
and we were discriminated against a
total of 300 people work for the EU
funded project which was launched by the
IOM and a local NGO the most important
aspect its members are made up of equal
numbers of returnees and local residents
that's to ensure there's no resentment
women also play a crucial role in the
reintegration of the returnees
our own children not among the returnees
but these young people could easily be
our children that's why we take care of
them soon the first chickens and eggs
will be sold with 300 participants
though the first payment will probably
be low but at least they'll earn some
income many young commands have lost
hope well-paid jobs are hard to find and
there aren't enough career options for
many escaping to Europe seems like the
only way out so the local job office and
the IOM have interviewed young people in
Conakry the interviews helped us
determine who is most likely to leave
the country illegally
we then selected them for a total of 21
projects such as the chicken farm and
now we're supporting them other young
people will hopefully be spared about
his terrible experience he now lives
with relatives in Conakry and is
studying
science for now at least he's given up
his dream of going to Europe all of my
friends warned me before I left but I
had to experience it for myself to
believe them all I would say to my
friends now is don't even try it
destroys you even if you do survive
either you feel so ashamed that you
didn't make it or you go crazy it's not
clear whether he can really stop his
friends from leaving the IOM estimates
that around 15,000 Ghanaians are still
waiting to be repatriated